[Music]
the loud house wouldn't be a hit without
the remarkable talents that bring the
characters to life these unseen stars
make the show what it is so let's get to
know them a little more you'll never
believe which loud sister shares a voice
with a Star Wars character if this is
your first time visiting our channel go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up now let's take a look at the
voices behind the loud house character
my dad say I have a million dollars mine
Khalil Harris and Andre Robinson
Clyde McBride is Lincoln lounge brainy
bestie his role in the show provides
quite a lot of funny moment the show
needs Clyde and Clyde needs his voice
unlike most characters on the show Clyde
has been voiced by two actors Khalil
Harris played Clyde for the first three
seasons of the show this talented kid
has appeared in numerous films and TV
series including the hit Castle Rock
Khalil has been praised for his
carefully chosen roles he voices the
character Franklin in peanuts that
character is historically important as
peanuts was the first comic strip to
tell the story of racially inclusive
friends Khalil was replaced on the loud
house in season three by Andre Robinson
Andre took over when Khalil's voice
began to change as he got older Andre
was already a star by the time he came
to the loud house he had roles in huge
movies like fences and hidden figures he
picked up Clyde where Khalil left off
and ran with the roll Grant Palmer and
Colin Dean some fans would argue that
the loud house is all about only brother
Lincoln so much of the story centers
around him and his troubles with so many
sisters if Lincoln is the main character
that makes the actors who've played him
the stars Grant Palmer played Lincoln
for the first 22 episodes of the show
grant is from California and believe it
or not his mom's name is Laurie Grant's
voice changed as he got older and was
replaced by Colin Dean Colin has
actually played link in the longest he's
been on the show for a total of 66
episode he's the only actor who's played
Lincoln for an entire season it's been
confirmed by the show that Colin will be
replaced by Tex Hammond Jax played
Lincoln in one episode of the show's
podcast he released a youtube video
announcing he landed the role but took
it down one day later you might find it
surprising that such an important
character has been played
so many actors it's pretty standard for
shows to recast a role especially when
the actors are kids young boys voice has
changed so much as they grow up that
it's hard for them to play the roles of
little kids for long Wayne Brady
the loud house has a pretty impressive
cast Wayne Brady is another of the
multi-talented powerhouses that make
this show so great Wayne never planned
on becoming an actor he had his heart
set on a career in the military a chance
performance in high school launched his
acting career Wayne is a singer stage
actor film actor voice actor and
comedian Wayne isn't afraid to tackle
tough work his role on the loud house is
no different he proudly plays Harold
McBride Harold and Howard are one of the
first married male couples in cartoon
history their roles are super important
just like Franklin and peanuts the
McBride family provides some important
representation there are lots of kids
with two dads who now get to see a
family like theirs in a fantastic show
having a talented actor in such an
important role is one of the many things
that makes this show such a hit Wayne
has won many awards including an Emmy
you may recognize him from his frequent
appearances on whose line is it anyway
Gradle I'll like a few other actors in
the loud house Gradle I'll plays more
than one role she plays Lola Lana and
Lily loud it really shows off her talent
that she voices three totally different
characters on the same show gray has a
huge resume that includes over 1,000
credits in over 300 titles her talent
seems to have been passed on to her son
text Hammond who we spoke about before
is set to take over the role of Lincoln
and guess who's his mom that's right
grade-a Lyle she's played a total of 18
other roles on the loud house as well as
three of the loud sisters
you may recognize her as the voice of
Mandy from the grim adventures of Billy
and Mandy that role was a natural choice
for gray as she loved goth music as a
teenager gray is also a talented senior
her musical career sparked her interest
in comedy as well as a comedian she
developed an impressive talent for
impressions being an impressionist was a
short leap from being a voice actor and
soon she was lending her voice to a
massive range of projects anyone who can
play over 1,000 different characters is
obviously very talented
dimaggio the loud house cast is
definitely star-studded there's no
denying that the shell is voiced by the
biggest names in the business John
DiMaggio is no exception this guy is a
voice acting megastar he provides the
iconic voice of bender on Futurama as
well as Jake the dog on adventure time
those two roles alone are enough to earn
him a spot and voice acting history he
has 830 credits to his name he was an
executive producer of know that voice a
documentary about voice acting he's been
on shows like Johnny Bravo Powerpuff
Girls and Teen Titans John plays over 15
characters on the loud house
John's famous for his gruff voice and
his ability to fake a Brooklyn accent
the star isn't even from New York but
nearby New Jersey his talent has won him
a ton of awards including a Kids Choice
Award his career shows no signs of
slowing down he landed a huge role on
the Netflix hit disenchantment the loud
house is obviously full of talent John
is a perfect example of just how
incredible the cast is Jessica to Chico
Lucy loud gets her voice from Jessica to
Chico Jessica also plays Lynne you might
think it's hard to play two characters
at once but jessica is a seasoned pro
she has almost 100 roles under her belt
can you imagine playing that many
characters she doesn't just play Lucy
and Lynne either Jessica's dad was an
actor when she was a kid she grew up
around show business in New York City
her career started when she was chosen
from thousands of other school kids to
appear in a TV special after that
Jessica's career took off no one in this
family ever willingly liked me to
experiment on man
Lara Jill Miller Laura Jill Miller
provides the voices for both Lisa loud
and Liam Lara is the only main voice
actor who's been credited in every
combined episode segment she plays 17
other roles on the show as well that's a
ton of characters on just one show Lara
had appeared in 47 different titles and
portrayed 80 separate characters Miss
Pennsylvania native played the adorable
Lambie on Doc McStuffins and won herself
a gaggle of fans her role as Lisa is
just as popular Laura had won a lot of
awards as a voice actor she's a talented
star who makes her characters shine with
a show as huge
as the loud house on a resume she's sure
to impress wherever she goes
Lilliana Moo me many of the actors on
the loud house played iconic characters
before working on the show Lilliana Moo
me is one of them she played the
unforgettable Myrtle Edmonds in lilo and
Stitch even bullies have their fans and
Myrtle is a beloved brat
that wasn't Liliana's only big role she
also played panini in chowder and
appeared in bravest warriors and
barnyard she's acted in front of the
camera as well with roles in the Santa
Clause too and Cheaper by the Dozen she
got her start at a young age child
acting runs in her blood her dad bill
Mumy
starred in lost in space when he was a
kid and even appeared in an episode of
The Twilight Zone it's no surprise she's
so talented with a dad like that on the
loud house she provides the voice of
Leni as well as a few minor roles
Liliana delivers a fantastic performance
as the absent-minded and ditzy Lenny the
second-oldest loud sister is sweet and
beautiful she makes us laugh with silly
lines mispronunciations and excellent
comedy delivery all of that awesomeness
wouldn't exist if it weren't for Lily
honest talent she perfectly demonstrates
the characters good nature and love for
her family Nika Futterman a few voice
actors on the loud house have also lent
their voices to Star Wars characters
that's the case for Anika Futterman too
she plays the role of Luna loud like
many of the other actors she's played a
few roles on the show in addition to one
of the loud sisters she's played over
240 characters in her career Nika is
from New York City and is very proud of
her Jewish heritage she would go on to
act in many cartoons including cat dog
Hey Arnold Teen Titans go and many more
she played the character in several
animated series and related video games
to the Star Wars franchise attracts a
lot of talented actors it makes sense
that so many Louds share their voices
with characters from the animated films
and games
Nika plays the musical loon allowed her
casting is no surprise as Nika herself
is a talented musician imagine Luna on
stage with rock stars Kathryn Tabor
Laurie loud gets her big personality
from voice actor Kathryn Tabor this
Georgia native is a star both behind the
scenes
in front of the camera unlike some voice
actors Catherine got her start in the
movies she starred in the film the girls
room and even co-starred in just like
heaven with Reese Witherspoon catherine
has lent her voice to over eight
animated projects including the loud
house
Laurie isn't even the only character
she's played on the show she has voiced
12 other roles Plus Laurie Lau she was
the voice of Amidala in Star Wars the
Clone Wars
she was also Princess Leia in Star Wars
detours sci-fi fans love Katherine and
some even refer to her as a gift goddess
she's even been a voice actor in several
video games
her voice is found in at least 20
different titles her love of games
doesn't stop at playing them or
appearing in them catherine started in
organization called games for soldiers
this group accepts donations of video
games and comic books for soldiers
deployed in Iraq and Afghanistan how
cool is that
she's a talented actor and a super nice
person Laurie loud just wouldn't be the
same if you were voiced by anyone else
well that's it for the voices behind the
loud house characters we'll see you soon
[Music]